hey guys welcome back to new rockstars
I'm Sam basher here with yet another one
of my MCU rewatch breakdowns
unfortunately today's video of my Doctor
Strange breakdown will be the last of
the series since the lovely people at
new rock stairs have already done
breakdowns for all the mother movies
that's cartoons the galaxy vol 2
spider-man homecoming Thor Ragnarok and
black panther you should go check those
all out after this video please watch
this video and appreciate it but I'm
glad you guys enjoyed this series and
I'll find something else to do pretty
soon but that doesn't matter today let's
take a look at the billion Easter eggs
that are hidden within this film spoiler
warning for Marvel movies comics TV
shows you know the drill let's keep
going with comic book Easter eggs so
let's kick it off with who is Doctor
Strange well he first appeared in
strange tales number 110 in July of 1963
and this wasn't his origin actually this
was just hopping in right in the middle
of his life in one of his adventures we
eventually do find out his origin and
how he became the sorcerer supreme which
is pretty much the same as it was in the
movie they did a pretty good job
adapting all of that he was a doctor he
smushed his fingers and he did help he
went to the ancient one he learned magic
and then he learned not to be a jerk ray
but a couple fun facts doctor Strange's
look is actually based on the actor
Vincent Price who Stan Lee and Steve
Ditko were huge fans of and actually
Steven strange his middle name is
actually Vincent as a not wink-wink
nudge-nudge - yeah you got it but moving
on to the beginning of this movie we're
introduced you come our tosh now this is
a fictional location in the comics
parently it's in this world somewhere in
Katmandu but in the comics it's usually
hidden away in the Himalayas I also just
wanted to give a nod to the magical
whips we see in this movie it's the main
weapon that most of these Sorcerer's
apparently used in the MCU normally the
doctor in the comic sometimes uses a
flaming whip as his main weapon there
are a few other weapons he likes to use
as well but I feel like this is the
closest connection from comics to movie
Fleming with there you go
now let's talk about Chi Caelius the
main villain of this movie now he first
appeared in strange tales vol 1
number 130 in March of 1965 he is a
villain of Doctor Strange way back when
and is actually an apprentice to Baron
Mordo because Baron Mordo usually has
just been a bad guy but moving on let's
talk about the ancient one who first
appeared in strange tales number 110 in
July of 1963 pretty simple is an ancient
sorcerer who lives in Conroe Taj where
he's been living there for centuries and
he teaches other Sorcerer's the ways of
magic now usually the ancient one is an
older Tibetan man but the MCU
tried to change this up a little bit
because some people have claimed that
the ancient one is more of a stereotype
that's why Tilda Swinton was cast
steer clear of all that but moving on to
when we actually introduced to dr.
Stephen strange we actually meet one of
the most famous characters from one of
the most important Doctor Strange comics
dr. Nick West or at Nicodemus West which
is his official name in Doctor Strange
the oath one of the best Doctor Strange
stories you should read I highly
recommend it now he plays a very
important sinister role in that story
and this he's just a normal doctor that
you know Doctor Strange in him kind of
butt heads sometimes there are a few
other nods to the oath in this movie but
I'll get to those in just a second let's
talk about Rachel McAdams character
Kristine Palmer who is the night nurse
well night nurse first appeared in night
nurse number one in November at 1972
then moving forward just a little bit to
when Doctor Strange is trying to teach
himself to write once again trying to
push through all that nerve damage this
is actually a copy pasted from the comic
specifically a Doctor Strange run with J
michael Straczynski also copying the
comic strange tries to use all of his
money ends up using all of his funds to
try to cure himself with normal means
that's just not enough let's talk about
Baron Mordo who first appeared in
strange tales number 111 in August 1963
now originally he in the comics was just
a normal sort of server then he turns
evil and he's been dr. Strange's
longest-running adversary in the comics
his motivations though are are different
from the movie at the end of this movie
we actually learned that he has kind of
a clear path of what he wants to do in
the comics he just want her and he runs
off and plays with demons moving for
let's talk about Master Hamir or the
fake ancient one that we meet right off
the bat when Doctor Strange goes into
Kumar Taj now Master Mir does appear in
the comics we actually find out to be
the father of Wong we'll talk about him
in just a second let's move forward and
talk about the astral plane er the
astral dimension how dr. strange has
been known to use his astral form many
many times in the comics even has this
cool fight with the Hulk during the
world war hulk event but the idea of the
astral plane appeared in strange tales
number 110 in July of 1963 also let's
talk about the dark dimension now the
dark dimension was created during the
Doctor Strange comic run way back when
and in this movie the entire look of the
dark dimension is actually directly
inspired by Steve Ditko's art who was
the co-creator of Doctor Strange but
with this dark dimension reveal and the
astral plane we learn about infinite
universes or the multiverse now Marvel
Comics has dabbled with the multiverse
many many times they're actually getting
a multiverse esque movie at the end of
this year with the animated spider-man
films starring Miles Morales but with
the introduction of the multiverse this
could open doors
to basically anything we could get any
kind of else world story would ever want
but as dr. trains flies through the Dark
Dimension we get at ease of Dormammu now
Dormammu first appeared in strange tales
number 126 in November and 1964 but to
talk about his backstory he's basically
a demon from another dimension
that's it you got it he's a bad guy but
moving forward we see the eye of
agamotto now the eye of agamotto first
speed and strange tales number 115 in
December of 1963 we find out through
history in history that there was a
sorcerer one of the first ones agamotto
who created a bunch of very powerful
objects one being the eye of agamotto
that sorcerers today actually use as a
weapon to wield magic and cast spells
but moving forward we're introduced to
dr. Strange's right-hand man wang hmm
wang first appeared in strange tales
number 110 in July of 1963 now usually
he is the manservant of dr. strange in
the sanctum sanctorum in New York but he
can you know perform some hand-to-hand
combat he's very proficient in that and
he usually as a very calm demeanor he's
not as Stern and strict as he is in this
movie but moving on we actually get some
nods to other fun little Easter eggs
from the Marvel Comics universe like the
staff of the Living Tribunal now the
Living Tribunal is a being in the Marvel
Comics universe which first appeared in
strange tales number 157 in June of 1967
now it's a bit of a bummer that the
power of the Living Tribunal only can go
into a stick that can collapse because
the Living Tribunal is usually the being
that maintains a balance across the
entire multiverse think about that
that's a crazy job for a being to have
but then it got whittled down to a
thumper also we get a name drop and we
see later the wand of watoomb which is
just a normal one that uses magics to
collect them and you know fire them to
cast spells and attack people you get it
but also we learned that Baron Mordo as
using the vaulting boots of Val tor
usually Valtor is a serpent deity in the
comics moving on we start to explore the
sanctum sanctorum there are some fun
Easter eggs worth pointing out like the
helmet of Black Knight who is a knight
who fights you know mystical threats in
the Marvel Universe which is very cool
also we meet the protector of the
sanctum and this man is Daniel drum and
this actually is a very cool connection
to another sorcerer supreme from the
Marvel Comics universe who is brother
voodoo
now brother voodoo first appeared in
strange tales number 169 in September
1973 but back to the rfx we actually get
to see and experience for a large chunk
of this may be the cloak of levitation
which first appeared in strange tales
number 114 in November of 1963 but
moving forward in the cloak tries to get
dr. strange to pick up that random
bondage locking system don't worry we'll
come back to that in a second you see
him running for some axes which is also
a very popular weapon of the doctor in
the comics but the assistant that he
ends up grabbing this has been confirmed
to be the crimson bands of cyttorak but
normally this is a spell not a device
that the doctor uses very often in the
comics now I do want to point out this
awesome fight between the evil
cassellius minion and dr. strange which
is a direct Pole from Doctor Strange the
of but now we're getting to the final
fight of the movie which is awesome for
so many reasons not just because of the
visuals but also it really sums up dr.
strange in a really cool way he's not
usually the guy to run into a fight and
punch somebody he's the fixer
so he ends up reversing an entire
superhero battle pretty cool
he asked me but moving forward we get a
cool name drop for the Infinity stone
and that dr. trench was just kind of
playing with it like it was a toy and
then to our first post-credit scene
let's give a shout out to the classic
gloves the Doctor Strange normally wears
I'll talk about this scene more as we
move into our MCU Easter eggs let's get
going let's give a shout out to the
marvel 3.0 logo this is the first time
we've seen it finally it's so cool
also the mirror dimension is an original
creation for this movie but there are
some inspirations from MC Escher's art
and fractal concepts also worth pointing
out that during dr. Strange's intro in
this movie we actually see a vendor's
tower in the background we also see it
later when dr. strange Baron Mordo or
facing kycilia
and his minions you see the Avengers
tower kind of fold in with the rest of
the city but speaking of the Avengers
the Avengers actually get a name drop
from long as the heroes of protect Earth
from physical threats while they protect
it from more mystical threats which is
very cool but moving forward to our
Dormammu vs. Doctor Strange scene
recently one of the writers of doctor
changes to come forward to say that
Doctor Strange may have been in there
longer than we thought he was in there
long enough confirmed by the writer to
become more of a master of his powers so
that's pretty cool
we only see about like 10 instances of
him trying to bargain with Dormammu
until he finally cracks
and listens to strange but I do like the
idea of him being in there longer than
we think and this kind of ties it back
to a fun theory about Groundhog Day the
Bill Murray movie that deals with time
loops which I'll come back to in just a
second now let's talk about the first
post credit scene now this was actually
directed by thor ragnarok director Taika
Waititi in this scene is in Ragnarok yet
to name drops to Loki and Odin since
Odin is missing and Thor and Loki need
to find out where he went also our
second post-credits scene is kind of a
tease to the sequel of Doctor Strange
whenever that happens cuz it hasn't been
confirmed just yet but Mordo has a new
mission he has taken the magic away from
King born o my guys let's talk about
some quick pop-culture references before
I have to go now I thought this was kind
of a fun fact about Benedict Cumberbatch
actually learned how to finger Tut
properly by Jay funk is a very popular
dancer you can actually just go to
YouTube or like what you're on YouTube
watching this you just type in J funk
after this video and check out some of
his dance videos they are very cool
although there's a bunch of fun
references to Pink Floyd you guys
probably heard interstellar overdrive'
playing during the car crash scene where
Doctor Strange messes up his fingers
also he's wearing a Pink Floyd shirt
when he's trying to call up all the
doctors to find a way to fix his hands
but speaking of the car crash let's talk
about the day that that car crash
happened it actually happened on
February 2nd you guys don't know if you
live outside the United States February
2nd the United States is Groundhog Day
coming back to the movie because in the
movie Groundhog Day Bill Murray's
character has to relive Groundhog Day
over and over and over and over again or
recently this theory has become very
popular that Bill Murray was in this
time loop for maybe thousands at least
hundreds of years maybe thousands of
years that kind of ties back to this
movie maybe dr. change was in there for
far longer than we thought
but shout out to the fan that was able
to find this out in scott derrickson
confirmed it because dr. Strange's watch
actually stopped the day of the accident
on february 2nd also worth pointing out
that during dr. Strange's first lesson
with the ancient one she actually makes
a real geometric pattern that is used in
spiritual healing called a Yantra now
these are usually uses energy centers
that create like spiritual portals or
vortexes that allows for energies to
heal you and helps with mystical
teaching you guys remember this scene
when dr. trenches playing with the time
stone he's making an apple raw and then
become a baby Apple again and become an
adult Apple again some of the creators
of this movie have stated that this is
supposed to be a symbol for the
forbidden fruit
because dr. strange ain't supposed to be
playing with that book you're not
supposed to play with time more
importantly there is a joke running
throughout this movie that you usually
get the instructions for something after
you've started using it or after you
probably messed up with it but at the
end of this movie this kind of pays off
in a way that the writers didn't intend
but a very clever fan was able to find
this notice at the very end of the
credits there is a warning to not text
and drive it's very dangerous and it
actually kind of ties in with the whole
you get the instructions at the end of
the story because art strange broke his
fingers during a car accident and
finally let's talk about the Stan Lee
cameo he is on the bus during the mirror
dimension fight but what is he reading
oh just the doors of perception as a
psychedelic book talks about opening
your mind and looking at the world
through different lenses and whatnot
guys we made it I hope you enjoy all
these Easter eggs and all the little
hidden references I was able to find
this movie was a toughy hopefully I
found all the ones you guys liked if you
guys learned something new let me know
in the comments or on twitter at sambhar
if I miss anything you guys well of
course let me know and I appreciate it
please like this video share with your
friends and subscribe for more
breakdowns we're doing some for infinity
war we're probably be doing those for a
very long time while also for The
Walking Dead when Wes world comes back
probably you guys are gonna want to know
more about that make sure you check out
new rockstars news as well I'm on that
panel it's a blast
again I'm Sam basher and I'll see you
next time